[Music]
my name is Alice running killing this
has been my whole life
we're here today to talk about our
destiny we're here to talk about the end
of the world everything has led to this
I can't run anymore and 48 hours
humanity will be no more there's a way
to end all this why should I trust you I
can't do something you want but I'm not
revenge
I'm probably developed cure and airborne
antivirus I have to get to the hive it's
our only chance now that's nothing
coming it's nothing big
oh my god there's an army of them in our
way what are we gonna do we're gonna
kill every last one of them
one man
dama
she killed your question yeah big
mistake
all this could end I'm gonna stop
umbrella whatever it takes
something stuck in us you sure this is
what I do
[Music]
I can't remember much before all this
started sometimes I feel like this has
been my whole life
ready
killing
my name is Alice and this is my story
the end my story
ten years ago in Raccoon City there was
an outbreak
and spread across the world within days
one way or another our world is coming
to an end the question is what we end
with it
umbrella developed an airborne antivirus
it would destroy the t-virus I have no
reason to believe a word you say true I
can obviously want very much revenge
Thomas I have to get to the hive we go
together
we're gonna kill every last one of them
and grab some gear
this is what I do
we played a long day you and I but now
it's over
oh you got
[Music]
yeah my name is Alice I worked for the
Umbrella Corporation there was an
instant your old guys died down here
the virus escaped everybody died
trouble was he didn't stay dead I've
been waiting years for it
the prodigal daughter returns
we played a long game you and I but now
it's over
you
my name is Alice
this is my story
yet
my story
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Capri day
[Music]
Attis what do you want from me
humanity will cease to exist so nice you
were trying to hide I trust you
behind you everything's led to this
what are we gonna do I'm gonna kill
every last one of them
Oh
what
[Music]
ah
I'm the prodigal daughter returns
baby she killed you in Washington
yeah big mistake
[Music]
this will be the state of our union
unless this election we make the right
choice vote Alice
a leader till the end this is what I do
resident evil' the final chapter this is
Milla Jovovich and I approve this
message this film is not yet rated my
name is Alice
ready killing
this has been my whole life
we're here today to talk about our
destiny we're here to talk about the end
of the world everything has led to this
I can't run anymore and 48 hours
humanity will be no more there is a way
to end all this why should I trust you I
have through something you are my
revenge
umbrella developed cure and airborne
antivirus I have to get my kiss
once my
dama
I should have killed your Washington
yeah big mistake
all this could end
to stop umbrella
something stuck in us you sure this is
what I do
you
[Music]
we're here to talk about the end of the
world
everything has led to this I can't run
anymore
ice and 48 hours humanity will be no
more
there's something coming
there's an army of undead in our way
what are we gonna do we're gonna kill
every last one of them
my name is Alice
[Music]
and this is my story
the end my story
biohazard the final
you
[Music]
we played a long game you and I
but now it's over
my name is Alice this is my story
the end of my story
biohazard the final the only thing
that's real fishy beneath us she's like
you of time very much like you